thank you very much for being with us
and just first of all
the march uh you're threatening now if
no new elections
are announced what what do you hope to
achieve
well mark
uh
what every
democrat hopes to achieve
from a peaceful
uh
protest
uh what i hope to achieve is
to show
the whole of the country
that the people of this country want one
thing elections they do not want
a foreign imposed government on uh
where
members of our party were
bought by
uh million dollars each was offered to
them to switch sides
uh and then
the government was removed
and so therefore we feel
that rather than someone else imposing a
government on our country let the people
of this country decide whoever they want
to to lead them
but you were
toppled you say by a western conspiracy
you call it i think u.s backed regime
change i mean it's quite a claim what
evidence
do you have what do you base that claim
on
well as a prime minister i get a cipher
cipher is the is a secret uh
a message sent by your ambassadors
they are sent to the foreign office
it's like in wikileaks you know
wikileaks was when they broke the code
so the secret messages were related to
the public so i get a cipher from my
ambassador in the u.s
and he it's an official meeting he has
with
this american under secretary or
whatever donald lou
and me as the prime minister i'm leading
i'm reading this cipher
and it says
that unless you remove your prime
minister through this vote of no
confidence which hadn't been tabled as
yet
there will be consequences for pakistan
and if you remove him all we will be
forgiven now this
this is what me as a prime minister
reading this cipher
and
i am the chief executive who who was he
asking
to have me removed
so the next day
after this meeting this meeting official
meeting with notetakers with minutes
between our ambassador in the washington
and this uh american official donna lou
next day
the no confidence portion is stable in
our national assembly
and then
members of our party which i told you
were
uh
had offered
offered these huge sums to switch sides
they'll start leaving our party our
allies leaving up leave a party and just
to remind you that at this time
in the last two years pakistan's growth
rate was 5.6 percent uh last year this
time was six percent it is one of the
highest growth rates
in in in pakistan's history right our
industry was
was booming
exports record remittances record
tax collection record
uh we coped with uh the krona virus we
are considered one of the five top
countries which saved the people and uh
our economy and our poor people from the
virus so there was no reason for the
government suddenly to be removed
because
uh
since since we've been removed by the
way the economy has gone in the tailspin
right so
let me just ask you about that so let me
just ask you about that because the the
us completely deny this and you say that
the u.s wanted you out
because of your foreign policy which was
increasingly anti-western and clearly
favoring
china and russia do you regret
the ties with russia specifically
given what's happened in ukraine
mark
in that cipher
donald ru is asking our ambassador that
did it
that
that the prime minister imran khan
was solely responsible for his decision
to tour russia
now the ambassador kept trying to
explain to him
that this was
a a tour which was planned long way back
long way before ukraine
secondly all stakeholders the foreign
office the military establishment we
were all on one page because the
military wanted hardware we wanted to
buy uh uh gas from because we got
depleting gas reserves we wanted to and
this was six years ago this contract was
being negotiated
from russia the problem
the problem is that on the very day
that putin invaded ukraine you shook
hands with him in the kremlin that
suggests if you know at least that you
endorse what he's doing in ukraine
mark how the hell was i supposed to know
that the day i landed in uh
in moscow he was going to putin was
going to go into ukraine but remember
even then from moscow
so hold on hold on
my statement as moscow was
i have never believed in military
solutions so never did i endorse that
ours was a totally bilateral uh a
meeting and
it was planned long before so point i'm
trying to make is that
we didn't realize that when i when i
would reach there that the
putin would go into ukraine how was i
supposed to know and how could you be
punished for that but do you expect this
is the picture how could you have but do
you accept that what russia is doing is
an illegal act of aggression do you
condemn what russia is doing
mark i am against all military
operations i was against iraq war i was
against u.s going to afghanistan
consistently i'm against military
solutions in ukraine to solve problems
but
point i'm trying to make is
that to hold me responsible
and
in this cipher it was only me being held
responsible while our ambassador was
telling us that this was a long uh
long before the store was planned the
purpose of going there were bilateral
things we had nothing to do with it but
even so
the problem is
but the problem is that the
ties you have with russia and china
suggests that you went ahead with that
meeting that human rights
are secondary to trade for you russia is
waging a war on its neighbor killing
civilians china has a terrible record on
human rights repressing the uyghurs and
other minorities
uh mark
i was elected by 220 million people of
pakistan to serve them
my number one priority is there are 50
million pakistanis below the poverty
line
i i was not elected for them to
to to correct all the wrongs that are
going on in the world my responsibility
was my country and so all my
relationships whether it was with china
with the united states
with
russia were for the benefit of our own
people listen
in kashmir which is a a dispute between
pakistan and india
india has violated all united nations
resolutions on kashmir they've illegally
taken away the right of the kashmiri
people and and basically got rid of the
statehood now
did anyone speak against it the
atrocities going on in kashmir 100 000
people in kashmiris have died has anyone
condemned india for that no because the
india is an ally
allow us to be neutral too so that we
can look after our own people what about
afghanistan are you are you pleased to
see the taliban back in control
in afghanistan were you pleased to see
the west defeated
mark
afghanistan
was there was never going to be a
military solution anyone who knows the
history of afghanistan and the british
above all have experienced three wars in
afghanistan the three times they've gone
into afghanistan in the 19th century
twice in 1901 in the 20th century
there was never going to be a military
solution people like us who kept saying
that this is not
you will not solve afghanistan problem
by bombing them or or sending your
military we were called pro taliban
people like us were always talking about
how would there be people in afghanistan
for 40 years they've been suffering but
at the end you said but at the end you
said it's not whether you are in one
ma this is not a football match whether
you're on one side or the other it's
trying
and where afghanistan when there are
problems there the country that suffers
most is pakistan because we sub we
already have three and a half billion
afghan refugees there but you said that
you said the chains of slavery had been
broken in the country
what when the americans left british
what did you mean by that was deliberate
it was deliberately
distorted i was speaking in urdu i was
talking about getting rid of
mental slavery we still have the
colonial education system with elite
is taught in english medium i was we had
first time in our history
had one syllabus for everyone and i said
that mental
mental slavery is far worse than
physical slavery in that context i i
refer to afghanistan where physical you
know uh they're fighting for their
freedom but what about the slavery of
women
iran what about the slavery of women are
they are you concerned that they seem to
be going back on their commitment
to allow girls back to school and
they're now insisting women cover their
faces are you worried at all about what
is happening there
mark
i am not responsible
or a spokesman for the taliban
if there was any other solution
after 20 years of war
well there should have been you should
have found some solution
the fact is
has supported the taliban
oh
who says this well
harboring harboring taliban fighters
inside pakistan
do you know something mark
there is so much propaganda and
ignorance about this whole pakistan
afghanistan situation
pakistan lost 80 000 people
no country would have deported the u.s
in the war on terror gives as many
sacrifices as we did the only reason we
lost 80 000 people was because we joined
the u.s war on terror because the u.s
was trying to find a military solution
in afghanistan where none existed we
were blamed a country that gave
sacrifices
we were blamed for the lack of success
in afghanistan we what is happening in
afghanistan has nothing to do with us
the fact is that
a war in afghanistan meant five million
refugees at the beginning in the 80s we
have three and a half billion refugees
we had what was the pakistan taliban
who were fighting against our state we
still have terrorism as a result of
participating in the u.s war
for pakistan to be blamed that three and
a half million refugees mark how do you
stop
how do we know who is uh who would go
across and and
and be with the taliban how so pakistan
first time we fenced our border there
was open border before so in our three
and a half years we have fenced the
border but
please do not blame pakistan pakistan is
the collateral damage of pakistan just
finally um
on the elections you want do you think
that people power you're talking about
two million people do you honestly think
that people power can
can take you back to power
uh
i'm not going to
i don't i'm not showing the two million
people coming out in islamabad so i
would get back into power
all we are saying is that this
uh the two problems one is that this is
an imposed government through a
regime change by washington
number two they're criminals
sixty percent of the cabinet is on bail
the prime minister and the chief
minister were about to be sentenced when
they were made the chief minister and
prime minister it's an insult to this
country all we are doing is peaceful
protest okay we feel let the people of
pakistan decide who they want to elect
let's not have an imposed government
from outside okay well as i say the
americans deny that but listen imran
khan thank you very much for being with
us this evening thank you thank you mark